Transnational organized crime
represents an acute threat to the United
States and to our neighbors in the
Western Hemisphere. In Mexico, for example,
drug cartels are taking advantage of
globalization in order to move their
product across borders, and to launder the assets through our own financial system.
They represent a serious threat to the
communities of Mexico, to our border, and
to, frankly, our international financial
system. There's a narco-state in
Venezuela that's gradually destroyed the
institutions in that country and
represents the threat to Venezuela's
neighbors, and a conduit for drug
trafficking to the United States. In
Colombia, we have narco guerrillas that
operate with virtual impunity over
decades, and now threaten the ability of
people there in Colombia to make peace.
The United States can be a partner with
all of our neighbors to tackle this
problem, use some asymmetrical tools to
freeze their assets, but also build up
the capacity of these countries to
confront this problem in their own
national territory.
How do you think the United States should work with its
neighbors to confront transnational
organized crime? Let us know in your
comments, and let us know what other
topics you'd like a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.